what CJ stri had to go through to get to
where he is now will inspire you yes the
outstanding rookie QB has already put
the NFL on notice when CJ was 13 his
father was incarcerated sending his
family into a financial freef fall this
would lead to CJ his mother and three
siblings to eventually move into a small
apartment above the storage unit where
she worked and on the field their
financial status showed as well CJ would
have blisters on his feet because they
couldn't afford new pleat and his youth
coaches would raise money for CJ to get
new contact lenses they couldn't afford
a QB coach to develop his skills so he
studied YouTube clips of Legends like
Drew Brees but against those odds CJ
never quit in high school he wouldn't
start until his junior year so he didn't
have a lot of buzz but as a senior he
threw for 47 touchdowns this led to the
offer that changed CJ's life forever
that offer will come from Ohio State
which he of course took setting him up
for one of the best college careers in
school history and now he's setting NFL
records as a rookie while taking care of
his family and working on his
relationship with his father